un tour aux états unis à présent avec la
reprise ce matin des auditions mais
commission spéciale sur l'assaut du
capitole c'était le 6 janvier dernier
quatre anciens proches de donald trump
convoqué oui il pourrait ne pas se
présenter sur les conseils de l'avocat
de l'ancien président américain en cas
d'absence les parlementaires se disent
prêts à lancer des poursuites celle les
explications thomas bonnin
c'est une journée décisive et
imprévisible qui s'annonce ce jeudi à
washington pour la reprise des auditions
la commission d' enquête parlementaire
en charge des événements du 6 janvier au
capitole ne sait pas si elle était moins
qu'elle a assigné seront bel et bien
présents initialement ce jeudi deux
anciens conseillers de donald trump
devait donc assister à ces auditions il
s'agit de cash patel et de steve banane
mais ce dernier ne devrait finalement
pas se présenter face aux parlementaires
c'est en tout cas ce qui est rapporté
par la presse américaine qui explique
qu'il suivrait ainsi les directives de
l'avocat de donald trump qui a invité
les quatre témoins assignés à ne pas se
rendre à ses convocations en vertu d'un
principe juridique qui s'appelle le
privilège exécutif et qui rend
confidentielles les communications
présidentielle c'est un aspect juridique
qui fait débat et du côté des membres de
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire on affirme être prêt à
lancer des poursuites en cas d'absence
de certains témoins écoutez je pense que
nous avons parfaitement à l'esprit que
si des gens refusent de répondre aux
questions refuse de fournir des
documents sans justification nous
retiendrons l'outragé et nous en
référons au département de justice
ces gens auront la possibilité de
coopérer ils auront l'opportunité de
venir et de travailler avec nous comme
il devrait s'ils ne le font pas alors
nous imposerons nos assignation alors
selon toute vraisemblance seuls deux des
quatre témoins assignés devrait bien se
rendre à ces auditions et en coulisses
les membres de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire réfléchissent donc
aux options et surtout au timing d'un
recours au département de justice
américain en cas d'absence donc de ces
témoins et puis il faut noter enfin que
onze autres personnes considérées comme
des organisateurs du rassemblement du 6
janvier dernier sont également conçus
emmenés par les travaux de cette enquête
parlementaire